fini de manger son pain noir alors jean
louis debré première action globale sur
ce scrutin ce soir avez vous le
sentiment que le gouvernement d'edouard
balladur sorte effectivement conforté
par ce scrutin est que l'action du
premier ministre soit finalement
avalisées par l'ensemble des français
je suis satisfait parce que un an après
les élections législatives
le rpr et l'udf nappe n'ont pas été
sanctionnés bien au contraire nous avons
nous progressons si on prend les
références 88 93 blessés légers at il de
93 sa montre à l'évidence qu'il n'y a
pas eu sur du pouvoir et que la sanction
n'a pas eu lieu que le désaveu n'a pas
eu lieu et que par conséquent nous
sommes dans la bonne direction
je suis satisfait aussi parce que non
seulement la majorité demeure la
majorité mais parce que l'opposition
demeure l'opposition et demeure
minoritaire
les français ont clairement marqué leur
soutien au gouvernement et à la majorité
qui soutient ce gouvernement alors merci
mais je devrai nous vous retrouverons
tout alors bien sûr pour un un débat en
compagnie de ségolène royal bon on l'a
entendu madame royal le parti socialiste
par la voix de michel rocard se déclare
lui aussi satisfait des résultats
satisfait si l'on prend en compte le
chiffre de 93 et des législatives
en revanche si la comparaison s'exerce
sur le scrutin du même type qui s'était
déroulé en 88 c'est un recul de près de
5 points pour le parti socialiste
oui vous me permettrez tout d'abord de
remercier quand même certains des
électeurs du département des deux sèvres
ceux du canton de melle de saint-maixent
la crèche et aussi de chef boutonne de
mauzé et de frontenay bon et ses
remerciements est en fait oui je crois
que si vous voulez que ces élections
cantonales sont d'abord des élections
qui sont gagnés sur le terrain et comme
cela a été dit à l'instant
je crois que il faut faire attention
dans les interprétations de politique
générale j'ajoute que cette
autosatisfaction un peu béate des forces
politiques me met un peu mal à l'aise et
mais probablement les français mal à
l'aise
c'est vrai qu'il n'ya pas eu de
discrédit du politique dans ces
élections cantonales puisque le taux
d'abstention n'est pas considérable mais
en même temps on observe que les villes
les banlieues et surtout les jeunes
n'ont pas voté
donc je crois que monsieur balladur a
tort de s'adresser à un autosatisfecit
comme il vient de le faire alors
qu'elles se risquent de michel rocard à
tort de s'adresser le même auto
satisfecit sur les titres et je trouve
qu'il a été très modérée il a dit la
gauche a fini de manger son pain noir je
trouve que c'est très modérée comme auto
satisfaction et je crois qu'il a raison
en effet ce qui m'a frappé au cours de
cette campagne c'est le fossé
considérable qui existe entre les
institutions les responsables politiques
et le peuple français tout simplement
donc je crois que c'est là dessus que
les partis politiques sont attendus pour
l'avenir et qui ne doivent pas faire
d'autosatisfaction nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler tout à l'heure
lors du débat que nous animons avec
gilles leclair et qui vous réunira en
compagnie de jean louis debré nous
allons faire un premier point sur les
résultats
gilles leclerc avec un problème